le nouveau prêt canadien aux apprentis
offrira près de 4000 $ cette publicité
du gouvernement fédéral fente un
programme de prêts aux apprentis ces
personnes qui sont en cours de formation
pour apprendre un métier mais de façon
étonnante cette pub contrevient à
plusieurs normes québécoises en matière
de santé et sécurité au travail
cet outil par exemple qu'on appelle une
rectifieuse ils devraient être munis
d'un protecteur de sécurité et d'une
poignée latérale
quant aux travailleurs qu'ils manipulent
en plus de ces lunettes convoi hills
il devrait porter une visière de
sécurité comme celle ci parce que si par
malheur le disque reprise
ces manquements pourrait entraîner pour
lui des blessures et peut-être même
causé sa mort ici les travailleurs ne
devrait jamais se trouver ou si près
d'une charge ni la tenir
alors qu'on la soulève de plus dans
cette scène on aurait dû délimiter la
zone de danger
un exemple avec des tréteaux comme ceci
ou une bande flexible en 2013 plus de
7000 québécois se sont blessés et dix
sont morts sur des chantiers de
construction
même dans une publicité qui plus est
gouvernementale
on ne devrait jamais prendre à la légère
la santé et la sécurité au travail